hello they are watching The Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see what's making
the headlines with the pr consultant
Alex Dean and the broadcaster and former
government Minister Anna subri great to
see both of you so let's take a look
shall we at the front pages starting
with the metro and the suspected Russian
missile attack on Poland is their top
story with the headline Putin's wore
Escalades Russian missiles hit Poland
that is also the lead story for the
guardian which reports that two people
were killed in the explosion near the
Polish border with Ukraine the telegraph
carries a picture of the devastation at
the scene and quotes the Ukrainian
president that an attack on one NATO
member is an attack on us all
while the time says that a senior U.S
intelligence source is blaming Russia
despite denials from the Kremlin
by the express reports on the death of a
young boy caused by the mold in his
family's flat saying that the story
shames Britain
the financial times carries a plea from
the chancellor to top Executives to curb
their own pay and to try to consider the
financial plight of their workers
struggling with the cost of living
crisis
The Daily Mail reporting that
universities have been told to
decolonize maths and Computing studies
or in its own words go woke in the way
they teach
the sun launches into the Cristiano
Ronaldo interview Saga with the
Manchester United footballer talking
about the death of his baby's son and
how he still talks to the child
and the star reports that the England
World Cup football team will have to
suffer the noise of bellowing camels at
night from the hotel in Qatar
well don't forget by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages after tomorrow's newspapers while
you watch us so let's head straight to
our guests we are joined by Anna and
Alex welcome to you um certainly a
serious night for NATO and European
allies if you look at the front pages uh
the Metro for example Anna um you know
we didn't want to see this did we
Russian missiles hit Poland clearly
there are plenty of questions
verification and caution but nonetheless
um serious for all of those involved
right now
absolutely and as we know two people
were killed whether that missile was
from Russia and deliberately fired to
Poland which it would be extraordinary
if that were and exceptionally serious
if that was the case or whether it's the
Fallout that you expect after a day
where the Russians have fired well over
80 missiles into Ukraine trying to take
out vital
um services like electricity and with
some success that was good to see
tonight that um the Ukraine was saying
they'd restored a lot of their
electricity but even if it's what are
cases I know there's a huge amount of
speculation about this but even if it's
the case that
um the Ukraine defense mechanism has in
some way sent some of its debris the
responsibility lies with Russia because
if they hadn't illegally invaded Ukraine
if they weren't continuing to bombard
this Sovereign Nation they then you
wouldn't have this terrible tragedy in
Poland but as you've been talking all
all evening this is this is serious
stuff and deeply concerning credit to
the papers because most of them have got
it on their front page they've turned it
around very quickly indeed so um yeah
the telegraph to Russian missile strikes
hit Poland with a view there of the
scene what looks like a crater to many
people an overturned trailer a tractor
in the distance as well um you know
grain suggested to certainly not a not a
Target and lots of things could have
happened it could be deliberate who
knows it could be an overshoot of a
missile it could be an intercepted
missile remnants falling where they
shouldn't or the Interceptor you know um
an air defense system itself Alex all of
that will be under investigation now but
will it be seen as Russia's fault
whatever the outcome of those
investigations do you think and and what
should happen now
well I I agree with entirely with the
thrust of Anna's answer I think that it
it is plainly Russia's fault whatever
the detail of what came to land on
Poland and explodes may be first of all
the strike that um Anna was discussing
with you I I thought it was over 100
missiles that Russia has fired that's
the largest bombardment on Ukraine of
missiles since they started this uh
invasion of a Sovereign Nation in
February uh to keep track of some people
that's nine months we've been living
with this the poor ukrainians have been
living with Russia's completely
unwarranted aggression for nine months
and this is merely the latest example in
it plainly it's Russia's fault but even
in wars and in conflicts which are
completely one-sided in blame like this
one sometimes accidents happen that
aren't uh to do with somebody doing
something deliberately I find it very
hard to imagine that Russia deliberately
launched uh two strikes on on targets of
no military or strategic value uh like
this on a NATO country a four miles uh
west of Poland's eastern border I'm
prepared to believe and I imagine many
better believe that the the detail of it
is accident that the Russians didn't
mean to hit Poland but the substance
that it speaks to a desperation on the
part of the Russians in this latest
state of their aggression and I think
that's really worrying actually the
desperation that's on show when they
launch attacks like this which have
ramifications and outcomes like this is
really worrying too so whilst we're here
there are lots of examples throughout
history of military strikes going wrong
and on you know amongst our allies I
mean the Americans when you're in the
Balkan conflict trying to strike Serbia
struck other countries around it that
that can happen and it does happen when
you're in the right as well as when
you're in the wrong as Russia is here so
I prepare to believe it's an accident
but it's desperately worrying well we're
hearing confirmation now that the head
of NATO will chair an emergency meeting
of the alliances 30 member states on
Wednesday at their headquarters Jen
stoltenberg the Secretary General
chairing that emergency meeting to
discuss this tragic incident uh we're
told that Reuters has reported the
ambassadors will meet at the request of
Poland on the basis of the alliance's
article 4 article 5 is the one we
normally talk about which is an attack
on one member is an attack on all only
invoked once for September the 11th an
extremely serious situation
um no doubt but so too as you said Anna
is the energy situation which knocked
out power to Moldova a gas pipeline to
Hungary knocked out power in the hakive
region at the time about half of Kiev 80
of leviv you know this is an energy war
on Europe but an infrastructure War now
on the ukrainians too
yes that's a really good way
unfortunately of putting it but it is
and I mean none of us have ever doubted
the seriousness of this because the
Danger's always been that uh as as Alex
says as we all know this has been going
on for nine months and I think we've
always talked about the danger is is
that it becomes such a factor of life
that it almost drops off the headlines
uh clearly that's not the case today
because this is so serious
um but I I agree with Alex the thing
about it shows you how desperate Putin
is it's it's it seems to be a
combination of the fact that he's not a
G20 even the uh president of China seems
to be distancing himself from Putin oh
thank goodness for that uh and and of
course they lost control of person so I
mean all round but it does it is
worrying because you know then you start
to get really worried as to what else
Putin might do because I think he's I
mean he's mad and dangerous exceedingly
dangerous and we all fit obviously the
nuclear threat because you know you
can't you can't say that that won't
happen because of the seriousness of the
situation and the situation Putin finds
himself
so confirmation then that the head of
NATO will chair an emergency meeting of
the alliance's 30 member states and
certainly the eu's council Chief Sean
Michelle had suggested that G20 leaders
should also meet on this or NATO allies
at the G20 should meet on this we know
that Joe Biden's been woken up been
briefed and has already spoken to the
Polish government and will certainly
keep an eye on that
um but in the meantime let's move on to
in a sense horrifying domestic matters
the tragic story of a boy as the Daily
Express puts it who died from mold which
shames Britain Alex
yes it's an appalling story I live in
southwark I live in the the council
Authority that this took place in I've
got plenty of
um of friends and colleagues in the Tory
party and the labor party too it's not a
part of political issue you live on the
Estates that are affected by things like
this and you can argue it's to do with
bad maintenance contracts or flat
roofing design which has led to this but
I gather but this is a very common
situation in the Estates
um around me that people have got um
this kind of mold uh and it can have
appalling deadly consequences but not
just that it happens but that it goes on
for months and years without being
addressed and that's going to be uh the
the real bad thing about this apart from
the appalling human tragedy of the
individual example it's the wider
systemic fact of the this thing
happening month after month and that in
the end I think is going to be something
that is going to go beyond one Coroner's
report it's going to go beyond one
appalling and tragic death it's a it's
pointing to a systemic failure to
prevent
um wider bad Health outcomes because for
every time you have one death you've got
hundreds perhaps uh many hundreds of
people who've had their health
deleteriously affected systemically that
is you know for months and years by by
this going on in Britain uh in the 21st
century well a defining moment too is
how the guardian uh have described it I
mean that's wishful thinking no doubt um
The Guardian reporting that about 450
000 homes in England have problem with
condensation and mold I presume that's
just the half of it actually many more I
think do but I'm accounted for
hmm
I I'm sure that's absolutely right Anna
and it is absolutely disgraceful and I
have to say there is nothing new in this
um I mean I remember when I was a member
of parliament people would write to you
with terrible stories about mold
infestations uh in properties and and it
all a lot of this comes down to local
authorities and I always thought that my
local Authority at rockstone took these
things
um very seriously and would take action
I suspect it's when you've got huge
housing schemes housing associations and
and local councils dealing with systemic
problems on a huge scale but you know
whether you're like it's all well and
good I saw the interview with Michael
saying you know man do your job and all
the rest of it I mean I don't disagree
that people often don't take
responsibility it's a feature of Modern
Life for these sorts of failings But
ultimately this comes down to money and
it then comes down to Global councils
and a lack of funding they would say to
make the investment that is desperately
needed or frankly to demolish in some
instances huge swains of public herb
public housing in order to make sure in
this day and age people live in
conditions they aren't going to kill
them and especially not little boys I
mean this poor little boy Age Two
they're absolutely shameful indictment
of our country in the mess we're in
totally I mean as a student I lived in a
room that was three quarters black with
mold you couldn't sit on the toilet
because they were literally mushrooms
growing around it
um and uh you know it was cheap that's
why we lived there cheap then is nothing
to what rents are now so these places
aren't even aren't even cheap to live in
is part of the problem isn't it anyway
um we'll see if there's action on that
lots more still to come including why
universities are being told to
decolonize maths and Computing according
to the Daily Mail
[Music]
thank you
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview let's just bring you the
very latest from the UK prime minister
Rishi Suna K who has just tweeted in the
last two minutes in fact I've just
spoken to the foreign secretary and the
defense secretary we are urgently
looking into reports of a missile strike
in Poland and will support our allies as
they establish what has happened we are
also coordinating with our International
Partners including NATO so the UK prime
minister in Bali suggestion of a meeting
in fact
um in Bali tomorrow and certainly the
head of NATO will chair an emergency
meeting of the alliance's 30 member
states on Wednesday at their
headquarters so we'll certainly keep an
eye on that
so as you saw the pl consultant Alex
Dean and the broadcaster and former
government Minister Anna subri are still
with us here
um let's go to the front of the Daily
Mail show shall we um Anna talking about
a woke agenda at universities your
thoughts
well I'm not going to give that 10
seconds worth because I I wouldn't
believe its accuracy and I'd want to
know more about it and I no doubt that
it's the Daily Mail picking up on
something rather obscure and and
stirring up Division and making up
nonsenses about work I mean woke to me
which I don't really even accept as a
word
um actually usually means people doing
the right thing and being rather
Pleasant and nice to each other and I'm
not much interest in the Daily Mail as
you probably can
I I can see that so we we will move on
and go to the financial times uh CNA
urges bosses to curb their pay and look
after their staff I mean you know all of
these stories are relating to what
happens on Thursday and the Autumn
statement
um you know how bad will it be and you
know how much will the right wing of the
conservative party who are perhaps
bruised after the Liz truss episode Alex
start flexing their muscles on this
well the conservative party needs to be
a party of low tax or at least lower tax
it'll lose its way even more if it
doesn't but the bigger problem for the
Prime Minister I think isn't about
individual policy it's about a sense of
purpose and Direction and I'm not
dodging your question because my point
is he can have it either way he can be
someone who says these are really tough
times I'm going to drive in this
direction and I'm afraid we are going to
need to raise your taxes but it's for
these purposes we're going to do it in
this way and if he does it persuasively
he may take his colleagues with him or
he may revert to the conservative
party's traditional position of a free
estate a Freer country as a lower tax
regime a Freer market and so forth and
he may take his quality with them that
way but the reason I say it that way
around is the biggest danger of the Tory
party isn't the labor party or concerns
about individual policies it's the
conservative party's parliamentary
membership which is now done in for
three prime ministers in a row and if
you think about it from that perspective
the individual policies take a second
position and okay to how loyal members
of parliament are prepared to be to the
prime minister of the day which used to
be an expression prime minister of the
day but is no longer an expression is
actually a statement of fact Alex we are
running out of time oh you stopped
anyway that's all right isn't it we we
have so much more to talk about thank
you both very much now Alex Dean and
Anna subri and luckily we have the 11 in
which to do it lots more lines too about
Rishi sunak and his meetings and
meetings to come but also let's tell you
about what's happening on our press
preview tomorrow night we will be joined
by a new Guest The Daily Mail columnist
Sarah Vine who will join up with the
associate editor of the Daily Mirror Kev
Maguire that is from 10 13.